the following is a conversation with ian
hutchinson a nuclear engineer
and plasma physicist at mit he has made
a number of important contributions in
plasma physics including the magnetic
confinement of plasmas
seeking to enable fusion reactions which
happens to be the
energy source of the stars to be used
for practical energy production
current nuclear reactors by the way are
based on fission as we discuss
ian has also written on the philosophy
of science and the relationship between
science
and religion arguing in particular
against scientism
which is a negative description of the
overreach of the scientific method
to questions not amenable to it on this
latter topic i recommend two of his
books
his new one can a scientist believe in
miracles where he answers more than 200
questions on all aspects of god and
science
and his earlier book on scientism called
monopolizing
knowledge as you may have seen already
i work hard on having an open mind
always questioning my assumptions and in
general marvel at the immense mystery of
everything around us
and the limitations of at least my
mind i'm not religious myself in that i
don't go to the synagogue a church or
mosque
but i see the beautiful bond in the
community that religion at its best can
create
i also see both in scientists and
religious leaders signs of arrogance
hypocrisy
greed and a will to power
we're human whether buddhist christian
hindu jewish muslim
agnostic or atheist this podcast is my
humble attempt to explore a complicated
human nature
what stanislav in his book solaris
called
our own labyrinth of dark passages and
secret chambers
i ask that you try to keep an open mind
as well
and be patient with the limitations of
mine
quick summary of the ads two new amazing
sponsors
sunbasket and powerdot please consider
supporting this podcast by going to
sunbasket.com lex and use code lex at
checkout
and go into powerdot.com lex and use
code lex
at checkout as well click the links buy
the stuff if you like
just visiting the site and considering
the purchase is really the best
way to support this podcast it's how
they know i sent you and based on that
that might sponsor the podcast in the
future
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it with 5 stars on apple
podcast
support on patreon or connect with me on
twitter
at lex friedman as usual i'll do a few
minutes of ads now
and never any ads in the middle that can
break the flow of the conversation
this show sponsored by sunbasket visit
sunbasket.com
and use codelex to get 35 bucks off
your order and to support this podcast
sunbasket delivers fresh
healthy delicious meals straight to your
door as you may know
my diet is pretty minimalist so it's
nice to get some healthy variety into
the mix
they make it super easy with everything
proportioned and ready to prep and cook
you can enjoy a delicious healthy dinner
in as little as 15 minutes
i just ordered my first set of meals
haven't gotten them yet
but i can't wait i just finished the uh
six mile run and thousand body weight
reps and i'm starving but let me risk
listing the actual menu items that i
ordered because they sound delicious
italian sausages and vegetable skewers
with two romescos
i don't actually know where mescals are
but the pictures looked awesome
and pork fried cauliflower rice with
carrots
and peas by the way cauliflower rice
is one of my favorite things ever
right now sun basket is offering 35
off your order when you go right now to
sunbasket.com
lex they told me to say right now with
urgency
so pause this podcast and go to the
website and make the purchase
or just go to the website and check it
out and enter a promo code lex
at checkout this show is also sponsored
by
powerdot get it at powerdot.com
lex and use code lex at checkout to get
20
off and to support this podcast this
thing is amazing
it's an e-stem electrical stimulation
device that i've been using
a lot for muscle recovery recently
mostly for my shoulders and legs
as i've been doing the 1000 body weight
reps and six miles every day
as i just finished they call it the
smart
muscle stimulator which is true since
the app that goes with it
is amazing it has 15 programs for
different body parts and guides you
through everything you need to do
i take recovery really seriously these
days and powerdot has been a powerful
addition
to the whole regime of stretching ice
massage and sleep and diet that i do
it's used by professional athletes and
by slightly insane
but mostly normal people like me it's
portable
so you can throw it in a bag and bring
it anywhere
get it at powerdot.com lex and use code
lex
checkout to get 20 off on top of the 30
day free trial
and to support this podcast and now
here's my conversation with ian
hutchinson
maybe it'd be nice to draw a distinction
between nuclear physics
and plasma physics what is the
distinction
nuclear physics is about the physics of
the nucleus and
my department department of nuclear
science and engineering at mit
is very concerned about all the
interactions and
reactions and and consequences of things
that go on in the nucleus including
nuclear energy
fission energy which is the nuclear
energy that we have already
and fusion energy which is the energy
source of the sun and stars
which we don't quite know how to turn
into practical energy
uh for humankind at the moment
that's what my research has mostly been
aimed at
but plasmas are essentially
the fourth state of matter so if you
think about
solid liquid gas plasma is the fourth
of those states of matter and it's
actually the state of matter which one
reaches
if one raises the temperature so
cold things you know like ice are solid
um liquids are hotter water
and if you heat water beyond 100 degrees
celsius it becomes gas
uh well that's true of most substances
and um plasma is a is a state of matter
in which the electrons are
unbound from the nuclei so they become
separated from the nuclei and can move
separately
so we have positively charged nuclei
and we have negatively charged electrons
then the net is
is still neutral electrically neutral
but a plasma conducts electricity
has all sorts of important properties
that are associated
with that separation and that's what
plasmas are all about
and the reason why my department is
interested in plasma physics very
strongly is because
most things well for one thing most
things in the universe are plasma
the vast majority of matter in the
universe is plasma but but most
particularly
stars and the sun are plasmas
because they're very hot and it's only
in very hot states
that nuclear fusion reactions take place
and we want to understand how to
implement those kind of phenomena
on earth maybe another distinction we
want to
try to get at is a difference between
fission and fusion
as you mentioned fusion is the kind of
reaction happening in the sun so what's
vision and what's fusion
well fission is taking heavy elements
like uranium and breaking them up
and it turns out that that process of
breaking up heavy elements releases
energy
what does it mean to be a heavy helmet
it means that there are many
nuclear particles in the nucleus itself
neutrons and protons um in the
in the nucleus itself so that in the
case of
um uranium there are 92
protons in each nucleus and even more
neutrons so that
the total number of nucleons
in the nucleus nucleons is short for for
either a proton or a neutron
the total number you know might be 235
that's
u235 or it might be 238
that's u238 so those are heavy elements
light elements by contrast have very few
nucleons protons or neutrons in the
nucleus
hydrogen is the lightest nucleus it has
one proton there are actually slightly
heavier forms
of hydrogen isotopes deuterium has
a proton and a neutron and tritium
has a proton and two neutrons so it has
total of three
nucleons in the new in the nucleus
well taking light elements
like isotopes of hydrogen and not
breaking them up but actually
fusing them together reacting them
together to produce heavier elements
typically helium okay which is helium is
a nucleus which has
has two protons and two neutrons
that also releases energy and that and
that or reactions like that
making heavier elements from lighter
elements
is what mostly powers the sun and stars
both fusion and fission release
approximately a million times more
energy per unit mass than chemical
reactions
so a chemical reaction means take
hydrogen take
oxygen react them together let's say and
get
water that releases energy the energy
released in a chemical reaction like
that or the burning of coal or
on oil or whatever else is about a
million times less
per unit mass than what is released in
nuclear reactions
so but it's hard to do it requires
very high energy of impact
and actually it's very easy to
understand why and that is that
those two nuclei if they're both let's
say
hydrogen nuclei one is let's say
deuterium and the other is let's say
tritium
they're both electrically charged and so
the and they're positively charged so
they they
like charges repel everyone knows that
right
so basically to get them close enough
together to react
you have to overcome the repulsion the
electric repulsion
of the two um nuclei from one another
and you have to get them extremely close
to one another in order for the nuclear
forces to overtake
the electrical forces and and actually
form a new nucleus
and so one requires very high energies
of
impact in order for reactions to take
place and those high energies of impact
correspond to very high temperatures
of random motion so that's why you can
do something like that
in the sun so we can build the sun
that's one way to do it
but uh on earth how do you create a
fusion
[Laughter]
reaction yeah well nature engineering
nature's fusion uh reactors are indeed
the stars
and uh they are very hot in the set in
the center
and re and they reach the point where
they
release more energy from those reactions
than they lose by radiation and
transport to the surface
and so forth and that's a state of
ignition
and and that's what we have to achieve
to
to give net energy it's like lighting a
fire
if you if you have a if you have a
bundle of sticks and you hold a match up
to it
and you see smoke coming from the sticks
but you take the match away and the
and the and the sticks just fizzle out
that's not
the reason they did it fizzled out is
that yes they were burning
there was smoke coming from them but
they were not ignited
but if you are able to take the match
away and they keep burning and they are
generating enough heat
to keep themselves hot and hence keep
the reactions going
that's chemical ignition well what we
need to do
what the stars do in order to generate
nuclear fusion energy is
they are ignited they are generated
enough energy to keep themselves hot
and that's what we've got to do on earth
if we're going to make
fusion work on earth but it's much
harder to do
on earth than it is you know in a star
because you know we need temperatures
of order tens of millions of
degrees celsius in order for the
reactions to go
fast enough to generate enough
electricity to keep it
or enough energy to keep it going and
and so um if you've got something that's
tens of millions of degrees
celsius and you want to keep it all
together and keep the heat in long
enough
to have enough reactions taking place
you can't just put it in a bottle
you know plastic or glass it would be
gone you know it's
in milliseconds um so
um you have to have some non-material
mechanism of confining the plasma
in the case of stars that non-material
force
is gravity so gravity is what holds a
star together it's what
holds the plasma in long enough for it
to react
and and and sustain itself by
the the fusion reactions but on earth
gravity is extremely weak i mean i don't
mean to say we don't fall yes we fall
but the the mutual gravitational
attraction
of small objects is very weak compared
with the electrical repulsion or any
other force that you can think about
on earth and so we need a stronger force
to keep the plasma together to confine
it
and the predominant attempt
at making fusion work on earth is to use
magnetic fields
to confine the plasma and that's what
i've worked on for much
essentially most of my career is to
understand
how we can and how best we can confine
these incredibly hot gases plasmas using
magnetic fields with the ultimate
objective
of releasing fusion energy on earth and
you know generating electricity with it
and powering our society with it
a dumb question so on top of the
magnetic fields
do you also need the plastic water
bottle walls or is it purely magnetic
fields
well actually what we do need walls
um those walls must be kept away from
the plasma because otherwise they'd be
melted or the plasma must be kept away
from them inside
inside of them but the main purpose of
the walls
is not to keep the plasma in it's to
keep the atmosphere out
so if we want to do it on earth where
there's air
we want the plasma to consist of
hydrogen isotopes or other things the
things we're trying to react
and by the way the density
of those plasmas at least in magnetic
confinement fusion
is very low it's maybe a million times
less
than the density of air in this room
so in order for a fusion reactor like
that to work
you have to keep all of the air out and
just keep the plasma in so yes there are
other things
but those are things that are relatively
easy i mean making a vacuum
these days is technologically quite
quite straightforward we know how to do
that
okay what we don't quite know how to do
is to make
a confinement uh device that
isolates the plasma well enough so that
it
so that it's able to keep itself burning
with its own reaction
so maybe can you talk about what a
takamaka is
the russian acronym from which the word
tokamak is built just means toroidal
magnetic chamber
so it's a toroidal chamber taurus is
is a geometric shape which is like a
doughnut with a hole down the middle
okay and so it's the so it's the meat of
the doughnut
okay that's the taurus um and it's
and it's got a magnetic field so that's
really all takamak
uh means but the particular
configuration
um that we're the that is very
widespread and there's the sort of
best prospect in the least in the near
term for making fusion energy work
is one in which there's a very strong
magnetic field
the the long way around the
doughnut around the torus um so you've
got to imagine that there's this
doughnut shape with an embedded magnetic
field just going round and round
the long way the the big advantage of
that
is that plasma particles
are when they're in a in the presence of
a magnetic field
feel strong forces from the magnetic
field and those forces
make the particles gyrate around the
direction
of the magnetic field line so basically
the particles follow helical orbits like
like a following like a spring that's
directed along the magnetic field
well if you make the magnetic field go
in inside this toroidal chamber and just
simply go round and round the chamber
then because of this helical orbit
the particles can't move fast across the
magnetic field
but they can move very quickly along the
magnetic field
and if you have a magnetic field that
doesn't leave the chamber
it doesn't matter if they move along the
magnetic field it does
it means it doesn't mean they're going
to exit the chamber
but if you just had a straight magnetic
field as you you know for example
coming from um you know a bar a
helmholtz coil or
or a bar magnet then you'd have to have
ends it would come would come to the end
ends of the chamber somewhere in the and
the particles would hit the ends and
and they would lose their energy so
that's why it's toroidal
and that's why we have a strong magnetic
field it's
providing a confinement against motion
in the in the direction that would lead
the particles to leave the chamber
it turns out that then here we're
getting a little bit technical but it
turns out that
a toroidal field alone is not enough and
so you need more
fields to produce true true confinement
of
plasma and we get those by passing a
current as well
through the plasma itself i can make
sure it stays on track
well that what that does is makes the
field lines themselves
into much bigger helices and
that for reasons that are too
complicated to explain
that clinches the confinement of the
particles
at least in terms of their single
particle orbits so they don't leave the
chamber
and so when the particles are flying
along this uh
this this doughnut the inside of the
donut
uh are they what's where's the
generation of the energy coming from are
they smashing
into each other yeah eventually i mean
in a fusion reactor
there will be deuterons and triti and
tritons and they will be
smashing in they will be very hot
they'll be 100 million degrees
celsius or something so they're moving
thermally with very large thermal
energies
in random directions and they will
collide with one another
and have fusion reactions when those
fusion reactions take place
energy is released large amounts of
energy is released in the form of
particles
one of the particles that's released is
an alpha particle which is also charged
and it's also confined
and that alpha particle stays in the in
the in the doughnut and heats the other
particles that are in that doughnut
so it transfers its energy to those and
they it keeps them hot
there's there's some leaking of heat all
the time a little bit of radiation
some transport and so forth there's also
a neutron released from that reaction
the neutron carries out four-fifths of
the fusion energy
and that will have to be captured in a
blanket that surrounds
the chamber in which we
take the energy drive
some kind of electrical
generator from you know thermal thermal
engine
um gas turbine or something like that
and power the power you got energy
so where do we stand where do we stand
on
getting this thing to be uh something
that actually works it generates energy
yep
well um there have been experiments that
have generated
net nuclear energies or nuclear powers
in the vicinity of
um you know a few tens of megawatts
for a few seconds so that's
you know 10 megajoules that's not much
energy
it's a few doughnuts worth of energy
okay yeah literal donut
that's right um
but um but we have studied how well
tokamax can confine plasmas and so we
now
understand in in rather great detail
um the way they work and we're able to
predict what is
going to be required in order to build a
tokamak that becomes self-sustaining
that that becomes essentially ignited
or very so close to ignited that it
doesn't matter
and and at the moment at least if you
use the modest magnetic field
values still very strong but but limited
limited magnetic field values
you have to build a very big device and
so we are at the moment
worldwide fusion research is
at the moment in the process of building
a very big experiment
that's located in the south of france
it's called eta
i-t-e-r which means the way or
just means the international tokamak
experimental reactor if you like
um and that experiment is designed to
reach this burning plasma state
and to generate about 500
megawatts of fusion power
for hundreds of seconds at a time it'll
still only be
an experiment it won't put electricity
on the grid or anything like that
it's it's to figure out what whether it
works and and with what the remaining
engineering challenges are it's a
scientific experiment
it won't be engineered to run round the
clock and
and so on and so forth which ultimately
one one needs to do
in order to make something that's
practical for generating electricity
but it will be the first demonstration
on earth
of a controlled fusion reaction reaction
for you know long time time periods is
that exciting to you
uh it it it's been an objective that is
in many ways motivated my entire career
and the career career of many people
like me in the field
um i have to admit though
that one of the problems with eta is
that it's an extremely big and expensive
and
long time to build experiment and so it
won't even come into operation
until about 2025 even though it's been
being built for
10 years and it's been it was designed
for 30 years before that
right and so that's actually one of the
big disappointments of my career
in a certain sense which is that we
won't get to
a burning fusion reaction until well
past the first
operation of eater and whether i'm alive
or not i don't know
but i certainly will be well and truly
retired by the time that happens
and so when i realized maybe some years
ago that that was going to be the case
it was a discouragement to me let's put
it like that
but if we can try to look maybe
in a ridiculous kind of way look into uh
100 years from now 200 years 500 years
from now
and we you know there's folks like elon
musk uh trying to uh travel outside the
solar system
i mean the amount of energy we need for
some of the exciting things we want to
do
in this world if we look again 100 years
from now
uh seems to be a very large amount
so do you think fusion energy will
eventually
uh sometime into your retirement uh
will be basically uh behind
most of the things we do look i
absolutely
think that fusion research is
completely justified in fact we should
be spending more time and effort on it
than we currently do
but it isn't going to be a magic bullet
that somehow
solves all the problems of energy by the
way that's a generic statement you can
make about
any energy source in my view i think
it's a grave mistake to think that
science
of any sort is suddenly going to find a
magic bullet for meeting all the energy
needs of society or any of the other
needs of society by the way
but and we can talk about that hopefully
later
but but but but fusion is very
worthwhile and we should be doing it
um and and so my disappointment
that i just expressed was in a certain
sense of personal disappointment
i do think that fusion energy is a
terrific challenge it's very difficult
to bring
the energy source of the sun and stars
down to earth
this does contrast in a certain sense
with fission energy by contrast fission
energy
efficient to build a fission reactor
proved to be amazingly easy
you know we did it um within a few years
of discovering nuclear fission people
had
figured out how to build a reactor and
did so
um you know during the second world war
which is by the way
fission is how the current nuclear power
plants work yeah
and so we have uh nuclear energy today
because fission uh reactors are
relatively easy to build you've got to
have what's hard is getting
the materials okay and that's just as
well because if everyone could get those
materials you know there would be
weapons proliferation and so forth
but it wasn't um all that long um
after even the discovery of nuclear
fission
that fission reactors were built and
fission reactors of course operated
before we had weapons
um so um
i think nuclear power is
obviously important to
meet the energy challenges of our
age it is completely intrinsically
completely
uh co2 emissions free
and in fact the wastes that come from
nuclear power whether it's fission or
fusion for that matter
are so moderate in quantity
that that we shouldn't really be worried
about them
um i mean yes fission products are
highly radioactive and
and we need to keep them away from
people but there's so little of them
it's that keeping them away from people
is not particularly difficult
and so while people complain a lot about
the
the drawbacks of fish and energy um
i think most of those complaints are
ill-informed
um we can talk about you know the the
challenges and the disasters if you like
of
uh off of fission reactors but i think
fission in the near term offers a
terrific opportunity
for environmentally friendly energy
which in which in the world as a whole
is rapidly being
taken advantage of you know china and
india and places like that
are rapidly building fission plants
we're not rapidly building fission
plants
in the u.s although we are actually
building two at the moment
um two new ones um but we do still
get 20 of our electricity from fish and
energy and we could get a lot more
so it's clean energy so it's clean
energy now
now again the concern is there's a very
popular
hbo show and just came out on chernobyl
uh there's the three mile island there's
fukushima that's the most recent
disaster
so there's a kind of a concern of um
yeah i mean nuclear disasters
is that what do you make of that kind of
uh concern especially if we look into
the future of fission energy based uh
reactors
well first of all let me say one or two
words about the contrast between fission
and fusion and then we'll come on to the
question of the
disasters and so forth fission does have
some drawbacks and they're
and they're largely to do with four
four main areas one is do we have enough
uranium or other
fissile fuels to to supply our energy
needs
for a long time the answer to that is
that we know we have
um enough uranium to support fission
energy
worldwide for thousands of years
but maybe not for millions of years okay
so that's resources um secondly
there there are issues to do with wastes
fission wastes
are highly radioactive and some of them
are volatile
and so for example um in
fukushima the the problem was
that some fraction of the fish and waste
were volatilized
and went out as a cloud and and polluted
air areas with um cesium
137 strontium 90 and things like that
so that's a challenge of fission um
there's a problem of
safety uh beyond that and that is
that um in fission it's hard to turn the
reactor off
when you turn when you stop the nuclear
reactions
there is still a lot of heat being
liberated from the fission products
and that is actually what the problem
was at fukushima
the fukushima reactors were shut down
the moment that the earthquake took
place
and they were shut down safely what then
happened
after that fukushima was you know there
were there was this enormous
tidal wave um many tens of meters high
that came through
and destroyed the electricity
grid feed to the fukushima reactors and
their
cooling was then turned off and it was
the after heat
of the turned off reactors that
eventually caused the problems that
led to release and so that so that is
that's a safety concern and then and
then
finally there's a problem of
proliferation
and that is that fission reactors need
fissile fuel
and the technologies for producing the
under
enriching and so forth the fuels can be
used can be
can be um by by bad actors
to generate um the materials needed for
a nuclear weapon and that's
a very very serious concern so those are
the four problems
fusion has major advantages in respect
of
all of those problems it has more uh
longer term um fuel resources
it has far more benign waste
issues the react the radioactivity from
fusion reactions is at least a hundred
times less than it is from fission
reactions
it has um no none essentially none of
this
after heat problem because it doesn't
produce fission products that are
highly radioactive and generating their
own heat
when it's turned off in fact the hard
part of fusion is turning it on not
turning it off
and and finally you don't need the same
uh
fission technology to do to make uh
fusion work and so it
there it's got terrific advantages from
the point of view of proliferation
control
so those are the those are four main
issues which make fusion seem attractive
technologically
um because they address some of the
problems of fission energy
i don't mean to say that fission energy
is overwhelmingly problematic
but clearly there have been catastrophes
associated with fission reactors
fukushima actually is i think in many
ways
often overstated as a disaster because
after all
nobody was killed by the reactors
essentially
zero and that's in the context
of a disaster a tsunami
that killed between 15 and 20 000
people instantaneous more or less
instantaneously
so you know in the scale of risks
um one should take the view that uh
in my in my in my estimation that um
fission energy came out of that looking
pretty good okay
of course that's not the popular
conception okay
yes that's gonna i mean with a lot of
things that threaten our well-being
we seem to be very uh bad
uh users of data we seem to be very
scared of
uh shark attacks and not at all scared
of
car accidents and this kind of
miscalculation and
i think from everything and i understand
uh
nuclear energy efficient based energy
goes into that category
it's one of the safest one of the
cleanest forms of energy
and yet the pr uh
whoever does the pr for nuclear energy
is not uh
has a hard job ahead of them at the
moment well i think part of that is
their association with nuclear weapons
right because when you say the word
nuclear people don't instantly think
about nuclear energy they think about
nuclear weapons
and and so there is you know perhaps
um a natural tendency to do that but yes
i agree with you people are very
poor at estimating risks and they react
emotionally not rationally in most of
these situations
can we talk about nuclear weapons just
for a little bit
so fission is the kind of reaction
that's central to the nuclear weapons we
have today
that's what sets them off that's what
sets them off
so if we look at the hydrogen bomb maybe
you can say how these different
weapons work so the earliest nuclear
weapons the
the nuclear bombs that were dropped on
japan etc etc
were pure fission weapons they used
uh enriched uranium or plutonium
and their energy is essentially entirely
derived
from fission reactions but
it was early realized that more energy
was available
if one could somehow combine a fission
bomb
with um fusion reactions
um because the fusion reactions
give more energy per unit mass than
than fission reactions and these were
this was called
the super you might have heard of the
expression the super or more simply
hydrogen bombs okay um
bombs which use isotopes of hydrogen and
the fusion reactions associated with
them
like you said it's hard to turn on it's
hard to turn on because you need very
high temperatures
and you need confinement of that
long enough for the reactions to take
place and so a bomb
actually a thermonuclear bomb
or a hydrogen bomb
has essentially
a chemical implosion
which then sets off a fission
explosion which then sets off
and compresses hydrogen isotopes
and other things which i don't know
because i don't i've never had a
security clearance okay so i so i can't
betray any
secrets about weapons because i've never
been a party to them but
because i know a lot about this problem
i
can guess okay um and sets off
fusion reactions in the middle okay so
that's basically
it's that sequence of things which
produce these enormous
you know multi-megaton uh bombs that
have very large yields um
and so fusion alone can't get can't get
you there
it is actually possible to set off or to
try to set off
little fusion bombs alone without the
surrounding fission explosion
and that is what is called laser fusion
so another approach to fusion which
actually is
mostly researched in the
weapons complex the national labs and so
forth
because it's more associated with the
technology of of weapons
is inertial fusion so if if you decide
instead of
trying to make your plasma just sit
there in this taurus in the in the
tokamak and
be controlled steady state with a
magnetic field if you if you're willing
to accept that
i'll just set off an explosion okay and
then i'll gather the energy from that
somehow i don't quite know how but let's
not ask that question too much
um then it is possible
to imagine generating fusion alone
explosions and and the way you do it is
you take
some small amount of deuterium tritium
fuel
you bombard it with energy from all
sides
and this is what the lasers are used for
extremely powerful at lasers
which compresses the pe the pelleted
fusion
and heats it it compresses it to such a
high
density and temperature that the
reactions take place very very quickly
and in fact they can take place so
quickly that they're
it's all over with before the thing
flies apart
wow and that is heated up really fast
that is inertial
fusion okay is that useful for
energy generation not yet
i mean there are those people who think
it will be but you may have heard of the
big experiment called the national
ignition facility which was built at
livermore starting
in the late 1990s and has been in
operation since
around about 2010. it was designed
in with the claim that it would reach
ignition fusion ignition
in this pulsed form where the reactions
have got over with
so quickly before the thing whole thing
flies apart it didn't actually reach
ignition and i
doesn't look as if it will although you
know we never know maybe people figure
out how to make it work better
but the answer is in principle it seems
possible
to reach ignition in this way maybe not
with that particular laser facility
are you surprised that uh
we humans haven't destroyed ourselves
given
that we've invented such powerful tools
of destruction
like what do you make of the the fact
that for many decades
we've had nuclear weapons now speaking
about estimating risk
at least to me it's exceptionally
surprising i was born in the soviet
union
that um that big egos
of the big leaders when rubbing up
against each other have not created uh
the kind of destruction
one was everybody was afraid of for
decades
well i must say i'm extremely thankful
that it hasn't i don't know whether i'm
surprised about it
i've never thought about it from the
point of view of
is it surprising that we've we've
avoided it i'm just very thankful that
we have i think that there
is a sense in which cooler heads have
prevailed at
crucial moments i think there is also
a sense in which you know mutually
assured destruction
um has in fact worked as
a policy to restrain the great powers
from going to war and in fact you know
the
the the fact that we haven't had
a world war you know since the 1940s
is perhaps even attributable to
nuclear weapons in a kind of strange and
peculiar way but i think humans
are deeply uh flawed
and sinful people and i certainly don't
feel gap that we're guaranteed that it's
going to go on like this
and we'll talk about the sort of the
biggest picture view of it all
uh but let me just ask in terms of your
worries
of if we look 100 years from now we're
in the middle of
what is now a natural pandemic that from
the looks of it
it fortunately is not as bad as it could
have possibly been if you look at the
spanish flu if you look at the history
of pandemics
if you look at all the possible
pandemics that could have been that that
folks like bill gates are exceptionally
terrified about we've
uh i know many people are suffering
uh but it's it's it's better than it
could have been uh so
and now we're talking about nuclear
weapons in terms of existential threats
to us
as sinful humans uh what worries you the
most
is it nuclear weapons is is it
natural pandemics engineered pandemics
nanotechnology in my field of artificial
intelligence some people
are afraid of uh killer robots and
robots yeah
is there do you think in those
existential terms uh
and and do any aspect do any of those
things worry you
i am certainly not confident that
my children and grandchildren will
experience the benefits of civilization
that i have enjoyed i think it's
possible for our civilizations to break
down
catastrophically i also
think that it's possible for our
civilizations to break down
progressively and i think they will
if we continue to have the explosion of
population on the planet that we
currently have
i mean it's quite it's quite
wrong to think of our problems as mostly
being co2
if we can just solve co2 then we can go
on
having this you know continually
expanding economy
everywhere in the world of course you
can't do that okay
i mean there is a finite you know
bearing capacity of our planet
on the resources of our planet on the
resources of our planet
and and we can't continue to do that so
i think there are lots of technical
reasons
why um a continually expanding
economy and and uh and civilization
is impossible and therefore um
actually i'm as much nervous about the
fact that our
population is eight billion or something
uh right now
worldwide as i am about um the fact that
you know a few million people would be
would be killed by
covet 19. i mean i don't want to be
callous about this but from the big
picture it seems like
that's much more of a problem
overpopulation
people not dying is ultimately more of a
problem
uh than people dying um so you know that
probably sounds incredibly callousy or
to listeners but i think it's simply you
know a sober assessment of the situation
is there is there ways from
the way those eight billion or seven
billion or whatever the number is
live that could make it sustainable
uh you know because you've kind of
implied there's a kind of uh
we have especially in the west this kind
of capitalist view of uh
really consuming a lot of resources is
there a way to
like if you could change uh one thing or
a few things what would you
change to make this life make it look
more likely that your grandchildren have
a better life than you well okay so
let's talk a bit about energy because
that's something i know a lot a lot
about having thought about it most of my
career
in order to reach a steady-state co2
level
okay that's acceptable in terms of
global climate change and so on and so
forth
we need to reduce our
carbon emissions by at least a factor of
10 worldwide
okay what's more
you know um the average
energy consumption and hence co2
emission of people in the world
is less than a tenth of what we
per capita of than what we have
in the west in america and europe and so
forth
so if you have in mind some utopia in
the future where we can where we've
reached a sustainable
use of energy and we've also reached
a situation in which there's far
less inequity in the world in the sense
that people have
share the energy resources more
uniformly
then what what that is equivalent to
would be to reduce
the co2 emissions in
western economies not by a factor of 10
but by a factor of 100 in other words
has to go down to one percent of what it
is now
okay yeah so you know when people talk
about
uh you know let's use natural gas
because you know maybe it
only uses 60 of the energy of coal
it's complete nonsense we that's not not
even scratching the surface of what we
would need to do so you know is that
going to be feasible
i i i very much doubt it
and therefore i actually doubt that we
can reach
um a level of energy
of fossil energy use that is one percent
of the current use in the west without
totally dramatic changes either in
you know our society our use of of
energy and so forth which actually
of course is much of that energy is used
for producing food and so on and so
forth so it's actually
not so obvious that we can we can get we
can cut down our energy usage by that
factor
or we've got to reduce the human
population population
so you run up against that number that's
increasing still
and you don't think that could be it's
depressing no it's not uh
it's not it's not it's not depressing
it's um
it's difficult like many truths are uh
do you do you have a hope uh that there
could be a technological solution
in short no there is no technological
solution
to for example for population control i
mean we have the technology
just you know to prevent ourselves
bearing children that's not a problem
technology's in okay solved
the challenge is society the challenges
human choices the challenges almost
entirely
human and sociological not technology
not technology and when people thought
talk about energy they
they think that there's some kind of
technological magic bullet for this but
there isn't
okay and and there isn't for the reasons
i just mentioned
not because it's obvious there isn't but
actually there isn't
uh and and in in any case um
that it's true of energy it's true of
pollution it's true of human population
it's true of
most of the big challenges in our
society
are not scientific or technological
challenges
they're human sociological challenges
and that's why i think it's a terrible
mistake
um even for folks like me who work at
you know
well the high temple of science and
technology
in in america and maybe in the galaxy
yeah i mean
you know it's it's it's mit it's mit
best university in the world
it's it's a terrible mistake if we give
the impression
that technology is going to solve it all
technology will make
tremendous contributions and i think
it's it's worth working on it
but it's a disaster if you think it's
going to solve all of our problems and
and actually um you know i've written a
whole book about
the question of of scientism and the and
the over
emphasis on science both as a way of of
solving problems
through technology but also as a way of
gaining knowledge i think it's not
all of the knowledge there is either
yeah i think that book
and uh your journey there is fascinating
so maybe you can go there can
can you tell me about your on a personal
side your
the personal journey of your faith of
christianity and your relationship with
uh
with god with religion in general
yeah in my in my latest book uh can a
scientist believe in miracles i
i i give a first i devote most of the
first chapter to telling how
how i became a christian um why i became
a christian i
i didn't grow up as a christian which is
fascinating i mean you didn't grow up as
a christian so you
you've discovered the beauty of uh god
and physics at the same time
that's a very poetic way of putting it
but yes i would accept that
um i became a christian when i was an
undergraduate at cambridge university
um i i had you know i had gone to a
school in which there was religion
kind of was part of the society there
were prayers and
at the at the at the daily you know
gathering of the
of the students uh the assembly of the
students um but i
but i didn't really believe it i just
sort of went along with it and it wasn't
particularly
you know aggressive or benign you know
blind it just sort of was there
um but i didn't believe it um i didn't
didn't make much sense to me but when i
but i came across christians from time
to time and when i went to cambridge
university
um two of my closest friends who
turned out were christians and i think
it was that
was the most important influence on me
um
that that here were uh
two people who were really smart like me
i i'm giving you my yeah my impression
at the time the way i the way i felt at
the time um
and and they thought christianity made
sense and and you know
testified to its significance in their
lives and
so that was a very important influence
on me
and i and ultimately i mean the reason i
i i hadn't i hadn't i didn't see
christianity as some kind of great evil
the way it's sometimes portrayed by the
by the radical atheists of this century
i mean i think that's nonsense but
but but i so i think there were certain
attractive things if you go to a
university like cambridge you know
you're surrounded by
by by western culture you know from from
about
you know the 15th century onwards and
that saturated
with christian art and architecture
and so forth and so it's hard it's hard
not to recognize
that christianity is in fact the
foundation of western society in western
culture
well western civilization um
so so i i mean maybe i was in that sense
favorably
disposed towards christianity as a
religion but as a personal faith it
didn't mean anything to me but i became
convinced really of two things one is
that
the evidence for the resurrection of
jesus christ is actually rather good
i mean it's not a proof it's not kind of
some some kind of scientific demonstrate
or mathematical demonstration
but it's actually extremely good it's
not scientific evidence by and large
it's historical evidence historical
evidence yeah
um so that was one thing and the other
thing that
came to me when i was at cambridge it
became clear
that christianity ultimately is not
you know some kind of moral
theory or philosophy or something like
that
it is or elite or at least it claims to
be um
a personal relationship with god which
is made possible
you know by um what jesus did and on the
cross and
and his life and his teaching and and
it's a personal call
to a relationship with god and
that had i'd never thought of it in
those terms when i was you know
when i was younger and that that that
thought became
um attractive to me i mean i i think
most people find the person of christ
and his teachings you know compelling
insert
in a certain sense what do you mean by
personal do you mean personal
for you like a relationship like it's a
meditative
like you specifically you even have
a connection uh with god uh
and and then the other side you say
personal um
with the actual body the person of jesus
christ
so all of those things what do you mean
by personal connection and why that was
me well so as well for the stupid
question
no that's okay no problem as a christian
i believe that i have a relationship
with god
which is best expressed by saying that
it's personal
and that comes about because you know
jesus through his acts has
reconciled me with god me a sinner
me someone full of of of
of sins of of failings of ways in which
i don't live up to even my own ideals
let alone the ideals of a holy god
have been reconciled to the creator of
everything
um and and so christians
myself included believe that prayer is
in a certain sense a connection with god
and there are times when i have felt you
know that god
spoke to me i don't mean necessarily
orally in words but
showed me things or enlightened me or
inspired me
in ways um that um
i i attribute to him so i see it as a
as a two-way you know relationship in a
certain sense of course it's a very
asymmetrical relationship but
nevertheless christians think that it's
a two-way
it's a two-way street we're not just
talking into the air when we
say we want i'm going to pray for
someone
in this two-way communication uh
is there a way that you could try to
describe on a podcast
what is god what is god like
uh in your view
if if you try to describe is it a force
um is it a is it uh for you
intellectually is a set of metaphors
that you use to reason
about the world is it um
is it uh is it is it kind of a computer
that does some computation that's the
infinitely powerful computer
uh or is it like santa claus a guy with
a with a beard
on the cloud like uh i don't mean um
i don't mean what god actually is i mean
in your limited
uh cognitive capacity as a human
what do you actually uh what do you find
helpful for thinking of what god
actually looks like what is
god well let me start by saying none of
the above okay
i mean clearly god in the christian god
um uh the god of abraham isaac and jacob
etc
um it is is not any of those things
because all of those things you just
mentioned
are phenomena or or or
entities in the created world and the
most fundamental thing
about monotheism as you know
abraham and moses and so forth handed it
down
is that god is not an entity within
the creation within the universe that
god is the creator of it all
and that's what genesis first two
chapters of genesis is really about
it's it's not it's not about telling us
you know how god created the world it's
about telling
us and telling the early hebrews that
god created
the world okay and that therefore he is
not you know simply an entity within
it on the other hand you know our finite
minds
have a pretty hard time encompassing
that so
so one has to therefore work in terms of
metaphors and images and
and so forth and um
i think we would know very little about
who god is um if we if it was simply uh
if we were simply left to our own
devices
you know if if we were just you know
here you are you're in the universe
try to figure out who who made it and uh
and so forth well you know philosophers
think they can
do a little bit of that maybe uh and
theologians think that they can do a
little bit more
but um but christians think
uh that god has actually helped us along
a lot
by revealing himself and and we say
that he's revealed himself supremely in
the person of jesus christ
um and so you know when jesus says to
his disciples if you've seen me you've
seen the father
then that is in a certain sense a watch
word for answering this question for
christians
it is that supremely if we want to
help ourselves understand who god really
is
we look to jesus we look to what he did
we look to what he
said uh and so forth um
and we believe that he
is one with the father and that's why we
believe you know in the trinity i mean
it's basically because
um that revelation is extremely um
central to christian belief and teaching
so in that in that sense through jesus
there was um that's kind of a historical
moment
that's profound that's really powerful
but do you also
think that god makes himself seen in
less obvious ways
in our world today absolutely
absolutely i mean it's it's certainly
been
the outlook of um
jews and christians throughout history
that god is seen in the creation that we
when we look at the creation
we see to some extent the wonder the
majesty the might of the person or
the entity but the person who created it
and and that's a way in which scientists
particularly
uh have over over the ages and
certainly over most of the last five
centuries since the
scientific revolution scientists have
seen in a certain sense the hand of god
in creation i mean
this leads us perhaps to a different
discussion but i mean
it's it's remarkable to me how
influential
um christianity and religion in
generally has been
in science yeah most of the scientists
through history as if
you described i mean god has been a very
big part of their life
and they were certainly up until the
beginning of the 20th century that was
the case
so maybe this is a good time to can you
tell me what scientism is
yeah i mean the short answer is that's
by scientism
we me we mean the belief that science is
all the real knowledge there is
um and that's a shorthand there are lots
of different facets of it and what which
one can explore and the book in which i
explored it
most most thoroughly was actually
an earlier book called monopolizing
knowledge and and the
the purpose of that title is to is to
draw
attention to the fact that in our
society as a whole
in particular in the west today we
we have grown so reliant on
science that we that we
tend to put aside other ways of getting
to know things
and so of course at mit we are focused
on science and we do
focus on it very much but the truth is
that there are many ways of getting to
know things
in our world know things reliably in our
world
and a lot of them are not science so
scientism in my view is a terrible
intellectual error it's to be
it's the belief that somehow the methods
of science as we've developed them with
ex
you know experiments and and in the end
they it relies
particularly upon reproducibility in the
world
and on a kind of clarity that comes from
measurements
and mathematics and related types of
of skills those powerful though they
are for finding out about the world
are not all the knowledge do not give us
all the knowledge we
we have and there's many other forms of
knowledge
and the illustration that i usually use
to to try to help people to think about
this is to say well look let's think
about human history i mean to what
extent can
human history be discovered
scientifically the answer is essentially
it can't
because and the reason is because human
history is not reproducible you can't do
reproducible experiments or observations
and
and go back and you know try it over
again it's
it's a one-off thing you know the
history is full of unique events
and and so you you know you you you
can't hope to do history
using the methods of science yeah i mean
in in some sense
history is a story of miracles i mean
they don't have to have
to do with god it's just uniqueness is
anyway unique events
these unique events and uh that science
doesn't like that because it's
uh unique events but they're very
definition or not
reproducible um can i ask sort of a
tricky question i don't even know what
atheist or atheism is but is it possible
for somebody to be an
atheist and avoid
um slipping into scientism oh yeah
absolutely
i mean i mean there the these are two
separate things okay
i'm quite sure there are many people who
don't believe in god and yet
recognize that there are many different
ways of we get
knowledge you know some is history some
is sociology economics
politics um philosophy
art history uh language
literature et cetera et cetera there are
many people who recognize those
disciplines as having their own
approaches to epistemology and to
get how we get knowledge and valuing
them very highly i don't mean to say
that
everyone you know who's an atheist
automatically you know subscribes to
scientific viewpoint that's not true but
it's certainly the case that many of the
arguments in fact most of the arguments
of the aggressive atheists of this
century people are sometimes called new
atheists although they're actually
rather old
most of their arguments are rather old
you know
are drawing heavily on scientism so when
they say things like
there's no evidence to support
christianity okay
what they are really focusing on is to
say
is saying that christianity isn't proved
or
the evidence for christianity is not
science okay science doesn't prove it
and and you you know if you read their
books that's what you find they really
mean
is science doesn't lead you necessarily
to believe in a creator god or into
in any particular in um
religion i accept that that's not a
problem to me
because i don't think that science is
all the knowledge there is and i think
there are other important ways of
getting to know
things and one of them is historical for
example and i mentioned earlier that i
think i became persuaded and i were
and i still am persuaded that the
historical evidence for the resurrection
is very
is very persuasive again it's not proof
or anything like that but it's but it's
pretty good evidence okay
yeah i've um i talked to richard dawkins
on this podcast and
um and uh i saw you debate with sean
carroll so
i i i understand this world it makes it
makes me very curious
but maybe uh let me ask sort of another
way
my own kind of uh world view maybe you
can help
as by way of therapy i understand
um you know because you kind of said
that there's other ways of knowing
what about if we cut if if i kind of sit
here
and am cognizant of the fact that i
almost don't know anything
so sort of i'm sit here almost paralyzed
by the the mystery of it all
and it's not even when you say there's
other ways of knowing
it it feels almost too confident to me
because uh yeah when i when i listen to
beautiful
music or see art there's something there
that's
and that's uh that's beyond the reach of
scientism i would say so
beyond the reach of uh the the tools of
science
but i don't even feel like that could be
an as an actual tool of knowing
it um yeah i just don't even know where
to begin
because it just feels like we know so
little like uh if we look even a hundred
years from now
when people look back to this time
humans look back to this time
they'll probably laugh at how little we
knew even a hundred years from now and
if we look at a thousand years from now
hopefully we're still alive or some
version of our
ai versions of ourselves
you know they they'll certainly laugh at
the absurdity of our beliefs
so what do you uh
so you don't seem to be as paralyzed by
how little we know
you confidently push on forward but what
do you make of that sense of
uh of just not knowing of the mystery
we need to be modest
or or humble if even
about what we know i accept that and i i
certainly think that's true not
not simply because in the future we'll
know more science and
there will be more powerful ways of
finding out about things
but simply because you know sometimes
we're not right
we're wrong okay in what we think we
know
um uh so that's crucial
but it's also a very christian
outlook that kind of humility
is what jesus taught so i so i don't
know whether this was in the back of
your mind when you were thinking about
this but it's often the case
that um people of religious faith are
are accused of being dogmatists
okay and there is a sense in which dogma
teaching
accepted teaching is is part of
religions
okay but i don't think that necessarily
uh uh that leads one
to blind dogmatism and i don't i
certainly don't think that faith
we can talk about this later if you'd
like but i certainly don't
think that faith means thinking you know
something and
not listening to counter arguments for
example um
so i i think that's crucial yeah what is
uh
what does faith mean to you what does it
feel like
what is it actually sort of how do you
carry your faith
in terms of the way you see the world
well i think
faith is very often misunderstood
in our society at the moment um because
uh it's often portrayed as
being nothing other than uh believing
things you know ain't true
you know um or or believing things that
are are not proven okay um
and um and this and faith does have
a strand which is to do with you know
basically believing
in uh in concepts or um
propositions but actually the word faith
is much broader than that
faith also means um
you know trusting in something
trusting in a person or trusting in a
thing
uh the reliability of some technology
for example
um that's equally part of the meaning of
the word faith
and and there's a third strand to the to
the meaning of the word as well
and that is loyalty so
you know i have faith in my wife and and
i try to act
in faith towards her and that's a kind
of loyalty
and so those three strands are the are
the most important
strands of the meaning of faith yes
belief in
in propositions that we might not have
you know full proof
about or maybe we have very little proof
about
but it's also trust and and loyalty
and actually in the in terms of the
christian faith
christians are far more called to trust
and loyalty than they are to belief in
things they don't
you know don't have proof of okay um but
but the critics of religion generally
um tend to emphasize the first one and
say well you know you believe things
for which you have no evidence okay
that's what that's what they think faith
is well
yeah there there is a sense in which
everybody
has to live their lives uh
believing or or or making decisions
in situations when they don't
have all the proof or evidence or
knowledge
that enables you to make a completely
um rational or well-informed or prudent
decision we
you know we do this all the time you
know my drive down here i nearly took a
wrong turning and i
thought which which way do i go do i
keep going straight on
and so my uh voice came out and i think
go straight okay
so so you have to make decisions and
sometimes
you know you don't have a navigation
system telling you what to do you just
have to make that decision with no
with insufficient evidence and you're
doing it all the time
as a human and that's part of being
sentient um
and so that kind of um
action and belief on the basis of
incomplete evidence
is not something that i feel
uncomfortable doing or i
feel that i feel on that somehow my
christian commitments have forced me to
do when i
wouldn't have had to have done it
otherwise i would have had to do it
anyway
um and and so you know there's a sense
in which um
i think it's important to see the
breadth of meaning of faith
and and and to recognize then certainly
in the case of christianity
um it's trust and loyalty that the the
key themes
that we're called to and i mean another
interesting extension of that that you
speak to
it's kind of loyalty is referring to uh
a connection with something outside of
yourself yeah
um so i think you've spoken about like
existentialism or even just atheism in
general as um
as leading naturally to an individualism
as a focus on the on the self
and uh ideas that maybe the
christian faith can instill in you is um
allowing you to sort of look outside of
yourself so connection
i mean loyalty fundamentally is about
other beings
and yeah other beings and i mean i think
i don't know what it is in me but i'm
very much drawn to that idea
and i think humans in general are drawn
to that idea
you can you can make all kinds of
evolutionary arguments all that kind of
stuff but uh
people always kind of tease me uh
because i talk about love a lot
and i mean there's a lot of uh
non-scientific things about love right
like what
what the heck is that thing why why do
we even need that thing
it uh it seems to be an annoying burden
that uh that we we get so much uh
joy in in life from a connection with
other human beings deep
uh lasting connections with human beings
same thing with loyalty
why why do we get so much value and
pleasure
and strength and meaning from loyalty
from a connection with somebody else
going through uh thick and thin with
somebody else going through some hard
times i mean
some of the you know the closest friends
i i have is going through some
some rough times together and that seems
to make life
deeply meaningful what is that
so yeah um i that's
that resonates with me and i obviously i
would i would affirm it um
i i think just to just to correct
the implication that you made i i don't
think it's necessarily
the co the consequence of atheism uh
that we
that we lose track of those kinds of
things i
i mean i think that atheists can be
loyal okay if you like
um the question more often
comes up in the context of you know
where does morality come from
and loyalty i think and duty are related
to one another you know if we have
loyalty to someone then we have a duty
to them
okay as well and i think that in so far
as we see ourselves as having some kinds
any kinds of duties or moral compulsions
with respect to our relationships to
other people
it's i think it's a question that always
arises well where does these where do
these come from
and there there are various approaches
that people have
towards deciding what makes
ethics or morality moral okay
but i do think it's the case that um
it's very hard to ground morality
um in in any kind of absolute way or
a persuasive way um
in mere human relationships
and so it's certainly the case that in
christianity
um there is a sense in which
um morality and
you know the morality of morals comes
from
a transcendent place from a transcendent
deity
and that we um that we
ground our the compelling
force of of morals on god
more than we do on individuals because
after all you know
if it if you if you've got nothing but
you know other people why should you
you know treat your neighbor well why
shouldn't you
defraud your neighbor if it's good for
you
well you know you can construct all
kinds of arguments and some of them are
you know obviously
arguments that are commonplace in
religion too you should do as you would
be done by and all this kind of thing
right but none of that seems any any
more than mere pragmatism to most people
okay and so that's what that's one of
the things if
that nature amongst others you know
really identified you know if god is
dead if the idea of god is grounding our
moral behavior
is no longer viable in the west which
nietzsche thought that it wasn't
okay then what does ground it and he had
no good answer for it
in fact he claimed there was no answer
but then he couldn't live with that
and so he invented the idea of the
ubermensch
you know this the superior human being
okay
and this was uh a different way of
trying to
ground morality not a very successful
one you know you could argue that
is the forerunner of the sort of uh
racism of hitler's regime and and
and so forth um that you know we've
in the west thankfully shied away from
uh in
in the past uh uh half or three quarters
of a century
but um you know i think it is the case
that uh christianity gives me
a basis for my
moral beliefs that is more than mere
pragmatism yeah but there is uh
so stepping outside of all of that there
does seem to be
a powerful stabilizing like we humans
are able to hold ideas
together like in a distributed way uh
outside of
whether god exists or not or any that
just
our ability to kind of converse together
towards a set of beliefs
uh into sometimes into tribes it's kind
of um
i don't know if it's inherent to being
human beings and
i hope not because now if i look on
twitter uh and there's uh
there's the red team and the blue team
right
it's almost like uh it's it's a charac
it's some kind of tv show that we're
living in
uh that people get into these tribes and
they hold a set of beliefs
that sometimes don't um i mean they
they are beliefs for the sake of holding
those beliefs and we get this
intimate connection between each other
for sharing those beliefs
and we spoke to the things about loyalty
and love and that's
the thing that people feel inside the
tribe and
it seems very human that within that
tribe those beliefs don't necessarily
always have to be connected to anything
it's just the fact that uh you know i've
uh did sports
uh uh my whole life whenever you're on a
team
the bond you get with other people on
the team is incredible
and the actual sport is is often the
silliest
i mean i don't play ball sports anymore
but the ball when i played like soccer
or tennis i mean
all those sports are silly right you're
playing with a little ball
but there's the bond you get is so
deeply meaningful so
i just it's interesting to me on on the
sociological level that um
it's it's possible to me whatever the
beliefs of religion
is um whatever they're actually grounded
in
they might be uh they might have a power
in themselves i think there is tribalism
everywhere and
i think tribalism in the u.s at the
moment is rather difficult to bear
from my point of view um and it's
i think fed by the internet and social
media and so forth but
but it's but historically tribalism is
has been a trait and remains a trait in
humans
the genius of christianity is
that it supersedes tribalism i mean
yes when the hebrews um
thought about yahweh initially
they thought about him as their tribal
deity just like the tribal deities round
about
about them and so but and and yet
from you know early on in
hebrew history the crucial thing that
yahweh
came to mean or i would say revealed
of himself to them was that he wasn't
just a tribal deity he was the
god that created the whole thing and if
he is the god of the whole thing then
he's not just the god
of the hebrews or in the case of
you know americans god is not just the
god of americans he's the god of
everybody
okay and that is a way
in a way the most amazing
transcending of tribal loyalties
and uh one of the crucial
you know occasions in the new testament
um
you know when the holy spirit comes at
pentecost
um you know the the the apostles and the
and the disciples speak in other tongues
and there are people from all
all the countries you know round about
hear them
in their own languages and so you know
whether
whether you take that as factual or not
that is the a statement of the
transcendent
um aspects of christianity or the
claimed
transcendent aspects of christianity
that it transcends culture
and that's certainly something which i
find appealing when i kind of uh
touch on this topic in my own mind uh
one of the hardest questions is
as is why is there suffering in the
world
do you have a good answer well i have i
have some answers
um but you're right that it is one of
the toughest questions
the problem of pain or the problem of
suffering um
or the problem of uh theodicy as
as theologians call it is is is probably
one of the toughest i think it's
important to
um say that there are certain types of
answers to this question
but there are aspects of this question
to which there is no
intellectual answer that is going to
satisfy
um and and the the fact of the matter is
you know when i'm speaking to an
audience
uh let's say um at some kind of lecture
i can be sure that there are peop there
are people
in that audience who are either
personally suffering they've got
illness they've got pains they're maybe
they're facing death
or someone in their family is in similar
sorts of situations so
suffering is a reality and and and there
is nothing that i
can say that is going to solve their
feeling of
agony and angst and and
maybe despair um in those types of
situations
there is really only one thing that i
think humans can do
for one another in those kinds of
situations and that is simply to be
there
to be there alongside your friend or
your
or your colleague or or whoever you know
family member or whoever it might be um
and that's the only really sense in
which we can give
comfort if we try to give intellectual
solutions to these problems were going
to be like
like the comforters that were in the
book of job in the
in the bible um who who brought no
comfort
to job himself um with their
intellectual answers but if they had
been there and some of them were there
they sat alongside
um that is some level of comfort um and
and after all that's the meaning of the
word compassion
it means to suffer alongside of somebody
and i would say first off you know what
does a christian say
about suffering the the first thing a
christian should say
is compassion is all that really counts
and what's more
we say that god has acted
in compassion towards us
that is to say he has suffered with us
in the person of jesus christ and when
we see the passion of jesus
we recognize that god takes
suffering deadly seriously has taken it
so seriously
that he's been willing to come and be a
part of his creation
in the person of of jesus christ and
suffer
death the most horrible death on the
cross
um and for our benefit so that's one
side of
of suffering but the question no the
philosophical question remains you know
surely if god is good you know and god
is
omnipotent um benevolent um
you know why doesn't he uh take away all
the suffering why doesn't he
cause miracles to occur that will take
away all this suffering
um i think there are some good answers
to that question um
in the in the following sense that um
you know we live in a world where
the consistency of the world is an
absolutely crucial part of it you know
the fact that our world
behaves reproducibly in the main
is absolutely essential for the
integrity
of our lives without it we wouldn't
exist
okay and so there is a sense in which
the integrity of creation
um calls for there being consistent
behavior which
you know these days we think of as being
the laws of nature
okay and so the consistent behavior of
nature
is very very important it's what enables
us to be what we are
um and if you're calling upon god in
in in in your critique of why isn't this
benevolent creator you know
fixing things um one answer is
he's fixed things in a certain sense
to have an integrity in them
and that integrity is the best thing
it's the way we have our existence the
way we live and move and have our being
and you know if you want something
different you've got to show
that there is a way in which you could
invent a world that is better
that it has the integrity that we need
to exist okay
and and and to be able to think and and
and
love and and be um but
but you were gonna do it better you know
and the atheists think that maybe they
have got a better idea but if they
thought about it a bit more carefully
they'd realize
no one has put forward a better idea
okay so the so another way
to say that uh i mean is that
suffering is an integral part of this
of um of a consistent
existence so so sort of uh
in the philosophical in a philosophical
sense
uh the full richness and the beauty of
our experience
would not be as beautiful would not be
as rich
if there was no suffering in the world
is that is that possible
well i think you said two different
things that aren't exactly at least that
aren't exactly the same
one is that suffering is an integral
part of
our experience you know that
might be considered a challenge to
certain types of
christian theology or or even jewish
theology in other words
christians talk about the fall and talk
about
uh adam and eve in the garden and and
have that have a
vision of there being some kind of pers
perception from
or or perfection from which we have
fallen and i think there is a perfection
from which we've fallen
but i don't think that perfection is
some kind of physical com
perfection in other words i don't
subscribe personally to the view
that some some christians do that there
was some state
prior to the fall in which death did not
occur
i don't think that that's consistent
with science as we know it
and i and i think that um death
for example has been part of the
biological
world and and the universe as a whole
um from from billions of years ago so
so just to be clear about that um you
know
i i on the other hand i do so
if that's the case then certainly in
that sense at the very least
um suffering or at least death okay
is part of the biological
existence and that probably seems so
completely obvious
to somebody who you know is okay with
science
whether they you know whether they're a
scientist or not well
so and i apologize if i'm interrupting
but it's the obvious reality of
of uh our life today but there's a lot
of people i think it's currently in
vogue
i've talked to quite a few folks who
kind of see as the goal
of many of our pursuits as to extend
life indefinitely a sort of uh
you know a dream for many people is to
live forever
uh but in the in this in the
technological world
in the engineering world in the
scientific world i mean that's that's
the big dream
to me it feels like
that's not a dream it's i certainly
would like to live forever
uh like that that's the initial feeling
the instinctual feeling
because you know life is so amazing but
then
if you actually kind of like you've
presented it if you actually
uh lived that kind of life you would
realize that that's actually a step
backwards that's a step down from the
experience of this life
in my sense that death is an essential
part of life
about the essential part of this
experience death of all things so the
thing the fact that things end somehow
and the scarcity of things somehow
create
the beauty of this experience that we
have
yeah transhumanism doesn't look very
attractive to me either
but it also doesn't look very feasible
um
but that's a whole big topic that i'm
not exactly an expert
but i'll say but i but you know i've i'm
of a certain age where
my mortality is more pressing or more
obvious to me than it once was okay
um and um and i don't
dread that i don't see that
as in a certain sense even
the enemy okay you're not afraid of
death well
i'm afraid of lots of things in a in a
in a conceptual way but it doesn't keep
me
awake at night okay um
i i'm i think like most people i'm more
afraid of pain than i am of death
so i i don't want to put myself forward
to some kind of hero that doesn't
worry about these things that's not true
but i i do think and then and
maybe this is part of my christian
outlook
um that there is life beyond the grave
um but i don't think that that it's life
in
this universe or in this um
certainly not in this body and maybe not
in a certain sense in this mind i mean
you know christian
christian belief in the afterlife is is
that we will be resurrected we will
in a certain sense be with god i don't
know what that means and i don't think
anybody else
really quite knows what that means but
there are lots of ways that
over history people artists and and
and writers and so forth have pictured
it um and these are all perhaps some of
them helpful ways of thinking
about it do you think it's possible to
know what happens after we die
um i i don't think we find out by
near-death experiences or those kinds of
things but
but i but i think that you know that
we have sufficient i feel i have
sufficient
information if you like um in terms of
god's revelation to be
confident that that i will
go somewhere else okay but it won't be
here
and i to me the
aspirations of transhumanism are
horrific i mean i think it would be a
nightmare not a dream
a nightmare you know to be somehow
downloaded into
a computer and live one's life like that
because it it completely discounts the
in
integrity of our bodies as well as our
minds i mean
we aren't just disembodied minds
it would not be me that was in the
computer
it would be something else if if that
kind of download were possible of course
it isn't possible and it's
very long way from being possible but
you know amazing things happen so we
shouldn't
be too cert so this is this is a place
that uh again maybe
taking a slight step outside uh we're
philosophizing a little bit uh let me
ask you about
uh human level or superhuman level
intelligence
uh the uh artificial intelligence
systems
do you what do you make from um
from almost a religious or a perspective
that we've been
talking about of the special aspect of
human nature
of us creating intelligence systems that
exhibit some elements
of that human nature is that something
again like we were talking about with
transhumanism
uh there's a feasibility question of how
hard is it to actually build machines or
human level intelligence
or have something like consciousness or
have all those kinds of human qualities
and then there's the do we want to
do that kind of thing so on both of
those directions what do you think
well okay so you know since your podcast
is called ai i don't want to
offend too many of your listeners out
there that's but i
but i i think one should be a little bit
more modest about one's claims for
ai than have typically been the case
yeah i think that actually a lot of
people in ai
are somewhat chastened and so there
there are more modest claims than
are common with the transhumanists and
yes and and so forth
um and you know i used to play
chess when i was a kid i was pretty good
at it okay
um he won competitions and so so on and
so forth
and i when i'm talking about when i was
in high school i thought it was
pretty unlikely that a computer would be
able to become
good at chess but i was dead wrong okay
and so you know
um how did that make you feel by the way
when um do you blew big kids
i stopped playing chess seriously
when i had when i encountered computers
that could beat me
okay i still play with my grandchildren
a little bit but
but um but yeah it it seemed like in a
certain sense it became a solved
problem uh when a.i was able to do it
better than i could
so i think that there are ways in which
today we've seen
um computers do things which
historically were regarded as being
very characteristic of human
intelligence
and in that sense there there is some
success to ai
i also think that um you know there are
certain things which one might think of
as being ai
which are you know completely widespread
in our society i'm thinking about the
internet
search engines uh um and so
forth which are enormously influential
and
obviously do things more powerfully than
any individual human or even any
combination of humans could do much
faster and
and and uh accessing
databases and so on and so forth all of
this is uh
outstripped our human intelligence
um i'm not sure the extent though to
which that is really
intelligence uh in the way that was
traditionally meant but it's certainly
amazingly
um facile and it
it multiplies our ability to access
human knowledge and and data and so
forth so
is that something is that enter the
realm of something we should be
concerned about
so in the realm of religion you talk
about what is good what is evil what is
right what is wrong
you have a set of morals set of beliefs
and when you have an entity come into
the picture
that that has quite a bit of power
if we potentially look into the future
and intelligence and capability
um do you think there's something that
religion can say
about artificial intelligence or is that
something you we shouldn't worry about
until it arrives you think
just like with the chess program um you
know religious writers have thought
about this for centuries
uh you know there's been a long debate
about
what is what it was historically called
the plurality of worlds
and it was actually more about whether
there are
places where other intelligent creatures
live than it was about us creating them
but but i think it's largely the same
question it's almost like aliens
yeah other intelligence so if there is
other intelligent life in the universe
what is its relationship to god okay
that is
in a certain sense the puzzle that
religious thinkers and writers have
thought about for a long time and
there's
a whole range of of different opinions
about that
i mean personally you know i think it's
it's an interesting question but it's
not a very pressing question at the
moment
um yeah and i think the same way about
the
the question of what happens if we're
able to build a sentient robot for
example
i think it's an interesting question and
we'll have to think about it when that
happens
but i think we're still quite a ways
away from that and so i
i don't have a good answer um but i
think there's a literature that you one
could tap
um to think about okay if you want to
start early on the question yeah
well let me ask you another impossible
question you know from a religious or
from a personal perspective
what do you think is consciousness this
this uh
subjective experience that we seem to be
having
does uh this does uh
the christian religion have something to
say about consciousness does your own
when you look in the mirror do you have
a sense of what is consciousness
um i think the bible doesn't have much
in the way of answers about that
directly in the sense that you're
perhaps asking it which is more like
i think you're asking for some kind of
uh quasi scientific or maybe indeed
scientific
uh uh description that's not really
looking for one yes
um i i think that i think that there
it's an interesting question i think
it's actually um
a it's a jump too far i think we have we
don't even know the answer to the
question what is the mind
let alone consciousness so if you
distinguish between those two things
i think the question that's being
addressed more directly
scientifically as well as in other ways
it is what is the mind and that is
certainly a very
topical question even in places like mit
which is not
historically involved with philosophical
questions you know that people
doing neuroscience and so forth i think
it's a very important question and i
think that we're going to find
that um we are not computers
in other words i think the the
commonplace theory of
what mind is is is generally speaking
by analogy that we are basically wet
wet wear okay um that we that we're some
computer-like entity
and that that the analogy to digital
computers
is is is a pretty decent one i mean that
that's of course a viewpoint
which um you know which drives
the aspirations of the transhumanists i
mean they they so much believe that our
minds are nothing
other than you know a certain sense some
kind of implementation of software
in biology that they say to themselves
well of course we're going to be able to
download
it into a into a digital computer i
don't think that's true
i think it's most likely that
quantum mechanics is very important in
the brain
uh it seems most unlikely that it's not
to me i know that that's contrary to the
opinions of many people but
but that's my view and it's also a view
for example of people like roger penrose
and people like that who've written
about it rather extensively
and if that's the case then really
my mind is not reproduce
reducible to some kind of software which
can be considered to be portable
it is so connected to the hardware
of my body that the two are inseparable
okay and so if that is in fact what we
find
um as i suspect will be the case then
the aspirations of the transhumanists
will be
very long in coming if at all
um so i think that actually physics and
chemistry
um you know are in a certain are in a
sense
um uh involved with the brain and within
the mind but not
in a very simple way like you know like
the
computer analogy um in in a much more
complicated way
and i also think that um
it's philosophically
ignorant to speak as if
um when and if the actions of the brain
are
are understood at the physical and
chemical level
that will me that the mind will vanish
as a concept you know that we'll just
say we're nothing but
brains okay of course it won't
i mean it may well be that our mind is
an emergent
phenomenon that comes out of the physics
and chemistry and biology
okay but it's also something that we
have to
encounter and take seriously and so
um you know it's it's not the case that
it that the mind is
reducible to nothing but
physics and chemistry even if it's
embedded in
you know continuously into physics and
chemistry as i rather suspect it is
um so i that that's my own view i mean
another way of putting it is that the
mind or the soul
is not something added into humans
as might have been the viewpoint um
historically i do think there is you
know there is something added to humans
but it's not
it's not the mind it's the spirit and
that takes us beyond the physical
context beyond this universe
but i but i don't think that that
consciousness the mind et cetera et
cetera
is that thing which is necessarily added
in explicit so i mean
i'm not a substance duelist in that
sense okay if you want to put it
philosophically
i mean um but you see you your senses um
so the mind and the intelligence and
consciousness can be these emergent
things
do you have do you have a hope a sense
that science could
help us get pretty far down the road of
understanding we will get much further
than we have and we it'll be interesting
um i mean right now our our methods of
diagnosing the human brain
are extremely primitive i mean the
resolution that we have
you know that comes out of uh out of nmr
and and brain scans and so forth is
miserable compared with what we need
in order to understand the brain at the
cellular level let alone at the
at the atomic level um but uh
you know we're making progress it's
relatively slow progress but it's
progress
and people are working on it and we're
going to get better at it and we'll find
out very interesting things as we do
um the time resolution is also
completely hopeless compared
compare with what we need to understand
the thought you know
so um so there's a long way to go and we
will get better at it
um but i'm but i'm not at all worried as
some people
are and some people speak as if there's
a good thing
that somehow the concepts of
humanity and the mind and religion
and and consciousness are going to
vanish
because we're going to have you know
complete uh
physical chemical description of the
brain in the near future
that we're not going to have that and
secondly even if we had it
the mind and all these other things
aren't going to vanish because of it
well i i find kind of compelling that
the notion that whoever created this
universe and us
uh did so to understand itself
himself i mean that there's this um
there's a powerful self reflection
notion to this whole experiment that
we're a part of
i certainly think that god takes delight
in his creation
and that it was created for that delight
as much as it was
um for any other reason and that
you know that therefore are there's
reason to be
hopeful and and awestruck by the
creation whether it's
on the very small or on the very large
i'm not sure if you're familiar there's
something called the simulation
hypothesis
that's been fun to talk about with the
computer scientists and so on which is a
kind of thought experiment that proposes
that you know the entirety of the world
around us is a kind of a computer
program
that's a simulation and then we're
living inside it
i think there's um i think from a
certain perspective that could be
consistent
with a religious view of the world
i mean you could just use different
terms uh basically
uh what are your but it's a it's a it
feels like a more
um modern updated version of that
but what is what's your sense of this uh
or the simulation hypothesis do you find
it interesting useful to think about it
do you find it ridiculous
did you find it fun what what are your
thoughts uh
it's fun and it's been of course the
subject of various movies yeah um
that that some of which are very well
known um
you know i don't think it makes sense to
think of it as a simulation hypothesis
in the sense that
we're really lying in uh
banks um of of uh
on banks of beds having our energy
drained away from us
um and and the simulation is going on in
our individual
brains that that makes no sense to me at
all i don't think that's what's
meant by the simulation hypothesis as as
you're using it now
but i think that there is a um
there is very little distinction between
saying
that a an intelligent creator
has set up the universe according to
his will and his plan
and set it in motion and is
allowing it to run out maybe as
christians say
he's sustaining it actually
um by his word of power it says in the
book
of the letter to hebrews okay
in in in this amazingly consistent
and um integrated way
um i don't think there's very much
difference between saying that and
saying that it's assimilation okay
i mean i think it's almost the same
thing okay
but i but i think from but i think it's
important to recognize that
the simulation in that concept the
simulation and the creation or the or
the universe are the same thing
okay in other words it's a simulation
you know that is billions of light years
across
okay yeah um i mean there's a sense in
which it helps
one understand especially if you're not
religious
that there is something outside of the
world that we live in
that there's something bigger than the
world we live in um
and that i mean it's just another
perspective on uh
that humbles humbles you um so
in that sense it's a powerful thought
experiment one shortcoming of that
is is the following is of the of the
analogy here's this
that we think of a simulation as
something take taking place
in the universe you know when we it's
it's taking place in my computer okay
i don't think that's the right analogy
for
um a christian view of creation okay
i don't think it's taking place in some
other
universe that god has made okay i think
maybe it's taking place in the mind of
god
christians might hypothesize also but i
but i think that that
that it's important to recognize that
christian theology at a
at any rate is that god is not one of
the entities in the universe and
and presumably therefore is very
different from a simulation that we
might run on a computer
let me ask you adam and eve even adam
ate of the fruit
of the tree of knowledge of good and
evil does this is this story meaningful
to you what does the story mean to you
yeah it is meaningful to me um i i take
the
you know the writings of the bible very
seriously and i think that
most christians regard them as having
some kind of authoritative
um role in their in their in their faith
um what do i get from it i mean i think
the most important thing that christians
get from the story of adam and eve and
eating the apple and so forth is that
the relationship
between humans and god is broken
has been broken by man's disobedience
that's what the the story of adam and
eve and the apple is all about
and um that that broken relationship
is for christians what jesus came
to redeem came to
overcome that brokenness and
restore that relationship with god
to some extent at any rate on earth and
and ultimately
um you know in in the in eternity to
restore it fully
so that's really what christians mean
and gain from the story of adam and eve
of course lots of people
ask the questions about how so how
literally should we take
these stories of particularly the first
few few chapters of genesis which is an
important question but
but i mean but we tend to um get bogged
down with it a bit too much
i think we should take away the message
um
and i think the the the uh
what the what actually we would have
seen if we'd been there
okay is something which is a matter of
speculation and it's certainly not
terribly important from the point of
view of christian theology
but it seems like a very important
moment
as a man of faith do you um
do you do you wish that uh i think it
was eve first
uh yeah we'll see do you wish
by the way it was just a fruit it was a
few you said it very carefully it was
the
fruit of the tree right
do you wish they wouldn't have eaten of
the tree i mean this is
back to our discussion of suffering was
that like an essential thing that needed
to happen
you're gonna have to read paradise last
to get your answer to that
beautifully put okay well let me ask the
the biggest question one that you also
touch in your book but one that i ask
every once in a while is what is the
meaning of life
the meaning of my life is many different
things okay but it but they are all kind
of
centered around relationships
i mean for a christian one's
relationship with god is
a crucial part of the meaning of life
but one's relationship with one's family
wife's
wife parents children grandchildren in
my case
and so forth those are crucially
important
these are all the places where people
whether they're religious or not
find meaning
but ultimately i think a person who has
faith in a creator
who we think has
a an intention or many intentions but uh
but
but but a will um
in respect of the world as a whole
that's
a crucial part of meaning and
the idea that my life might have some
small significance in the plan
of that creator is
an amazingly powerful idea
that give that brings meaning um
i i tell a story in my book that um when
i was a student
before i became a christian i read a
philosophy book whose
approximate title was um what you know
what is the meaning of life
and you know that book basically said
there is no meaning to life you have to
make up the meaning as you go along
and i think that's probably the the
predominant secular view
is these days that there is no real
meaning but you can make up a meaning
and
that will give you meaning into your
life um
i don't subscribe to that view anymore
um i think there is more meaning than
that um but i do think that those things
which give meaning to our life are very
important and we should emphasize them
and you you have said that as the part
of the
as the part of that meaning is the part
of your faith uh
love and loyalty are key parts
so can you try to say
what is uh love and loyalty
like what
what does it mean to you
what does it look like
if you were to give advice to uh to your
children grandchildren of what to look
for
in and looking for loyalty and and love
what would you try to say well i think
it's something like
yielding your will or
desire to another um
it's valuing others more highly
or at least as highly as yourself but
that's just the start of it because true
love
re you reach a point where you are
you feel compelled by the other
uh and that i think to some
people sounds very scary but actually
it's terrifically liberating um
and i think that love then brings you
into service towards
another and i'm you know reminded of
um the phrase from the anglican
uh prayer book where it talks about um
jesus whose service is perfect freedom
in other words
for us christians to serve god
is what perfects our freedom and i think
there is
an amazing love as um
is in part capped captivity
but in a kind of paradoxical sense
it's also an amazing freedom love is
freedom
i don't think there's a better way to
end it we started with fusion energy
and ending on love and there's a huge
honor to talk to you thank you so much
for your time today thanks it was a
pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation with ian hutchinson and
thank you
to our sponsors sunbasket and powerdot
please consider supporting this podcast
by going to
sunbasket.com lex and use codelex at
checkout
and go to powerdot.com lex
and use code lex at checkout click the
links
buy the stuff even just visiting the
site
is really the best way to support this
podcast
because it helps convince them to
sponsor it in the future
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it with five stars on
apple podcast
support on patreon or connect with me on
twitter
at lex friedman spelled somehow without
the letter e
just f-r-i-d-m-a-n and now
let me leave you with some words from
arthur c clarke
finally i would like to assure my many
buddhists christian
hindu jewish and muslim friends that i
am sincerely happy
that the religion which chance has given
you has contributed to your peace of
mind
and often as western medical science now
reluctantly admits to your physical
well-being
perhaps it is better to be unsane and
happy
than sane and unhappy but it is the best
of all
to be sane and happy whether our
descendants can achieve that goal
will be the greatest challenge of the
future indeed it may well decide
whether we have any future
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time